Deion Sanders refuses to have any
captains on his team which means no
players have the classic C on their
Jersey instead coach Prime uses
something way different if you look at
Travis Hunter and Jace feely's jerseys
they say d that d stands for dogs and he
spells it like that but then if you look
at shador Sanders and Shane Coke's
jerseys you'll see an L that L stands
for leader these four guys participate
in the coin toss like what typical
captains would do but coach Prime does
not and I repeat does not believe in
Captains he believes in leaders and dogs
and he said every leader ain't a dog and
every dog ain't a leader regardless of
what he's calling his players the
Colorado boys they're here to play